- We are living in the internet age.
- [Woman] Why don't people get this more
and foster, I mean
- Because people look backwards
instead of looking forward.
90 percent of people default
into looking behind them,
instead of looking ahead of them.
It's the human psyche.
I think most people are scared of change,
and they look for negatives.
(classical-influenced pop music)
Yeah!
I don't know.
Just so happy you're part of the team.
Ahh!
Literally something about that scene
that was so perfect for me!
Morning, Vlog.
Nine AM here in Stockholm.
Gorgeous.
Nice background.
I'm with a bunch of good looking men here.
We're about to go to some meetings.
Super excited about the day.
Getting a lot done, yes.
Oh, thank you very much.
Here's my good friend,
ArcticStartup
- Yes.
- You guys might have
saw that headline.
- Finland 100 Independence Day today.
- Finland's hundred?
- Yes.
- Independence,
from who?
- From Russia.
- I thought so.
(laughs)
I know my history.
Anyway,
see you in a second.
Bunch of meetings, got my keynote.
Couple of recaps before we go into today.
Gonna give you some edits here, Babin.
Number one, pop it fully in,
in full, full edit mode.
The $1.80 Strategy is crushing.
I want you to start deploying the
18 cent strategy.
You're gonna drop $1.80 a day,
two cents at a time.
Nine top posts times 10
different hashtags everyday,
and that will massively
build up your audience.
Shane, everybody wants to talk.
The way to win is to listen
and then contribute.
Everybody wants to put
a picture of themselves
like you, looking cool, running,
but I looked at your social and
just like 99 percent
of the people watching,
nobody's listening yet.
That's okay, that's
not discouraging to me.
Nobody listened to me at first either.
Let me say it one more time.
For over a year, nobody watched my
(bleep) shows on YouTube.
The way to be discovered is to either
put out great content,
have one great piece of content go viral
and then everybody discovers you,
or become part of the community.
You're gonna get exposure,
you're gonna get some followers,
you're gonna contribute,
but you're also gonna learn because
you're gonna watch
90 pieces of content
doing well on Instagram
which is then gonna inspire
and help you strategize
the content that you yourself are gonna
put out on Instagram.
That's a good use of three hours a day.
I'm getting tweeted, DM'ed,
emailed like (bleep) crazy.
When I taste something,
like the 2017 Flip Challenge
that I know brings value to you,
an amazing thing is happening.
People are blown away that
one of the best strategies in social media
is being social.
Understand it, watch this clip.
Actually, you know what?
I got nothing else to say.
Get that in,
let's go on to the rest of the day.
- [Man] Exactly
- And that taste of
like, actually doing it.
- Exactly, exactly.
- It shows you then how to run all (bleep)
- Right because you have
friends that have been
working in the place for 15 months,
still haven't done anything.
- Exactly, like making coffee and like
printing things out for
their boss and that's it!
It's just incredible and like I say,
a year went past,
built the processes from the ground up.
I said to Jenna, look,
I don't actually think
I'm learning anymore,
I think I'm just following processes now.
And within a month I'm on grand tour,
and running like the biggest spend that
had, pretty much autonomously as well.
And that just, that I don't know
whatever happened anywhere else.
- Yeah I know.
- It's so good.
And that's the way you learn
and the way you develop
and as you say, I have
friends that go work in
finance or for other agencies
and they don't do anything
for two years, three years.
In two or three years
- The game changes.
- Exactly!
So much that's
- There's no substitute for doing.
- No.
Literally.
- I'd rather,
you know, the other thing,
the biggest mistake that business makers
business owners make,
or companies make is
when they don't let somebody do something
for two or three years,
they don't know if the person's good!
- Exactly.
- So you've paid for two or three years
(laughs)
you've not done anything productive
and then they get exposed
once they hit the field
- Yeah, exactly to the point.
- Just a bad strategy.
To me it's like,
it's offense versus defense.
For me the reason we
put you in that position
and everybody in that position is to
we believe, and
if unfortunately it doesn't work out,
quicker to learn, you know?
- Yeah.
- You're not gonna know
if you're good at skiing
by watching videos.
You're gonna learn by getting on there
and finding out.
- 100 percent, yeah.
- Yep, they're waiting inside.
- Thank you very much.
See you later.
- Take care.
- Thank you.
- [Man] Hello, Sebastian.
- Sebastian.
Real pleasure.
- Thanks.
- [Gary V] Yeah, where do you want me?
Let's go this way.
- Yeah so what's up, Gary?
How you doin'?
- Life is good.
- Man,
I've been following you since
two years back.
- Thank you.
- And, I mean, it's crazy when I
saw your style and the
vibe you sent out there,
to your audience and I just felt like,
this is the thing I need
to put some energy on.
- I appreciate it.
- I didn't know nothing about filming,
so I went out filming with my cell phone,
and client were buying my
- Films, clips
- Basically.
- Love it.
- And I got into this,
selling content for companies.
- Yes.
- So I've been working for two years,
got a little bit bigger camera
- Yes.
- Got some people around me that's gonna
potentially be
- Surround yourself
with good looking people
- Good
- Smart, smart strategy.
- They're better than me.
- I get it.
- I mean it's thanks to you, man.
Honestly.
- That makes me
very happy, brother.
I was the seed but you nurtured it, right?
- Yeah.
- So when people are like,
you did it, thanks to you,
I'm like,
I'm doing it for everybody!
I'm doing it for the culture
for the community.
I'm doing it.
But the people that grab it
and do something about it,
you know?
I'm just creating the conversation.
I'm forcing the conversation.
And the way I do it,
down people's throats.
But I'm fascinated by the people that
listen and watch, and are like, yeah.
Listen and watch and say (bleep) you,
(bleep) him.
But most importantly,
listen and watch and then
go do something.
That's the more interesting part.
And the reason I talk
so much about patience
is a lot of people watch me,
start something, and then
give up 10 days later.
10 days.
Silly.
I think the next step is to
not overly think about the next step.
You know like those cliche things like
if you want to get on top of the mountain,
it's like one step at a time.
I believe in that (bleep).
I think the biggest thing
that cripples a guy like you
two years in, starting to build something,
you get a little taste
and you want more, right?
That's always a dangerous part.
I'm very scared, usually
at year two, three, four
of a little bit of momentum.
That's where a lot of
people try to go too fast
and break the whole thing,
get a little fancy, get
either content or too hungry.
It's about staying in the middle.
And remembering what got you there.
I mean, look.
I'm a great example of it.
I always want people
to watch me carefully,
like I'm winning, I've gotten fancy,
and I'm getting less fancy.
You know, as good things
are happening for me,
I'm trying to go more tried and true.
As the light gleams,
I'm trying go more into
being an operator.
I'm gonna speak less next year,
I'm gonna operate more,
I'm gonna do more HR and see my people.
I think it's just important to,
I don't think about what's next.
Ever.
Like, of course I'm thinking every day
about what I want to do that's going to
help me win.
But I don't think of it as next.
I think people look at it, like,
you know?
And I just look at it like
And so, I think the best
way to have something happen
that's going to bring you value is
remembering what got you there.
What got you to where you are right now
is you got motivated.
You took a camera from your phone and
you started doing (bleep) and then
good (bleep) started happening
and I think a lot of
people start overthinking.
And putting too much
pressure on themselves
for what's next.
I see a lot of companies
and people go from
zero to a million dollars,
and then stick at a million
for five or six years
and they beat themselves up.
And I always remind them
that that's incredible,
but more importantly, I try to remind them
that the reason you're not growing is
you changed when you got
from zero to a million.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- And so, for me,
as I get more fame and
recognition and opportunity,
I'm tripling down on humility
and patience.
I think the guy or girl
that has my position
is always in the best position.
I think when you're selling something new,
it's less early bird gets the worm
and it's more second
mouse gets the cheese.
- Wow.
- There's a lot of people that
don't want to work with us,
because I'm the one that most upset them.
And it's the second or third.
- Wow.
- Yeah!
- I can imagine.
- Yeah.
- How do you do that then,
how do you even know?
- I mean,
I get enough for what
I'm looking for, right?
- Yeah.
- You know, it's all relative, right?
- How do you transcend
with your platform,
you create a lot of
leads, obviously.
- Yes.
- How do you convert them?
- By running an actual good business.
- Yeah.
- You know?
Bye.
- [Man] Wanna get a selfie?
- Yes of course.
Of course.
- Thanks man.
- I wish you well.
- I'll email you then.
- Please.
- Yeah.
We'll come and visit you.
- That'd be very nice.
The basketball team?
I'm a real fan.
'Cause they haven't won yet!
- I probably watch the Rangers
more than you watch the Rangers.
- Yeah, I bet at this point.
Babin!
Babin, this is it!
This is, you've been waiting for this,
why don't you go take a picture?
This horse lamp is
hi everybody!
(bell ding)
Give Babin some love!
(multiple bell dings)
Little more, good!
- [Woman] We will take
approximately over there
approximately 25 minutes of your time.
- [Gary] No problem.
I don't think this is as generational
as people think.
I think this is more psychology than it is
none of the four people
sitting in this room,
Babin's young, but the
three of, you're pretty
how old are you?
- 35.
- Yeah
- [Woman] Gary's talking
to our sound engineer.
- That's right.
I bring everybody into these podcasts,
I like to break the walls
and visualize for you
everybody who's listening.
Look,
the three of us didn't,
35, you know,
it's not about how old you are,
I'm 42 and I feel more curious
and more understanding of
the culture and the game
than plenty of people that are 18.
I think it's a mindset.
And so, it's a very
interesting time to be alive.
There's so much opportunity and
I'm excited to be a part of it.
I only want one thing
for people that I have.
Really, outside of health,
the only thing I wish for people is them
to love what they do as much as I do.
When I do new podcasts or new video shows,
I love reading the
comments of the audience
that don't know me.
Inevitably,
five percent of the audience
will leave a comment that refers to
drugs.
If they want to be really snarky,
they'll say I, you know,
cocaine, ritalin,
they think that I'm on something.
And I always reply because
I've never tried smoking a cigarette,
let alone done adderral.
I reply with
so they'll say, cocaine.
I'll reply, gratitude.
I'm so grateful that I
do what I love everyday,
and what I love for clarification is
just being an entrepreneur!
Playing.
The challenges, the risk, the excitement.
- [Woman] But you're also
high on your own energy.
You have tremendous energy.
- I have tremendous energy
because it builds momentum.
When you're doing what
you want to be doing
for a long period of time,
it builds momentum.
I didn't have this same energy in school.
I hated school.
I was optimistic, I was high energy
that's my DNA.
But not like this, this is now a supernova
because now I'm 20 years
into being in my zone.
The breath of fresh air, the exhale
I had on the first day that I worked
at my dad's liquor store,
like worked,
there was no more school ever again.
That
(exhales)
was incredible.
Just posted something on Instagram,
For The Mindset.
I'm getting more and more
intrigued by mindset.
Because I used to think of it as fluffy,
like self help.
And now I think of it more as strategy.
What's your strategy in life?
Somebody asked me,
on Instagram after I posted this,
Gary, if the mindset has been skewed,
how can you bring it back?
And I answered with
by surrounding yourself with people who
have the mindset you aspire to.
My friends, please understand that
mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our
opinions are controllable.
The key is to add more
people with optimism,
and cut people with negativity.
It's very, very simple.
Now it's very hard to cut
people with pessimism,
cynicism, and negativity
when they are the people
that are the closest to you.
Parents, siblings, spouse.
But the bottom line is,
if you're asking the question,
I'm gonna give you the answer.
The answer is, add more people
with positivity and optimism,
and cut people with
pessimism and cynicism.
Who you surround yourself matters.
What content you consume matters.
I basically suffocate myself
for a long period of my time
and created an environment
that was based on
offense and optimism,
and now I know no different.
Please do the same for you.
Make that move.
Mold, and I mean mold
your mindset by what you consume
and with whom you consume it.
- [Man] Julien, nice to meet you Gary!
- Good to see you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Such a pleasure.
How are you guys?
- Just fine, how about you?
- Hey nice to meet you, Gary.
- How are you?
- First of all, I am so inspired by
your whole career, everything you've done,
and your social work as well.
How do you do to stay in shape?
- Mentally or physically?
- Physically.
- Physically I travel with a trainer.
- Yeah.
- Which was a huge commitment I made.
And I try to watch what I eat
but I work out every single day.
- Yeah.
- Seven days a week
I'm in a gym.
- That's amazing.
Because I actually saw before
I saw you had something
in your back pocket.
It's a donut!
(laughs)
- I love it.
- Hey man.
- I eat those too.
(laughs)
But that just makes me work
for an extra 20 minutes.
- Yeah!
- I love it.
- But it's funny because they
actually showing up whenever
- Yes.
In my armpit too.
Yes.
- If you hold your hand like that,
and we have two of them,
so I take
one of the donuts in my hand
and you squeeze this one
really tight in your hand.
- Okay.
- And then I take this one invisibly,
and I place it back into your hand.
Did you felt anything?
(laughs)
- I'm gonna have two donuts, aren't I?
Jesus.
- If I pull out one, two
how many do you have left?
- I'm supposed to have two.
But I have a funny feeling I don't.
(laughs)
- Open your hand, like bam!
- Yeah.
I have a lot,
I have a lot of donuts.
(laughs)
- That's crazy.
- Crazy, right?
What do you think, Mom?
- [Woman] Yeah I think
you know they are so,
when you do something
- They're all in.
- [Woman] Yeah, they're all in.
Sometimes too much.
- Yeah.
I understand.
You know, honestly, honestly,
honestly that's an
interesting observation.
I really think, to be successful,
it has to be sometimes too much.
- Yeah.
- To be successful when
everybody else wants it too,
it has to be 110 percent
- Yeah
- Not 97.
And everybody wants to be 97
- Yeah
- And what people don't realize is
I don't even think it takes 100.
I think it's 102.
- Yeah.
- I dream strategy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Gary you work about
14, 15 hours everyday.
- I believe it, man.
- You know the deal.
- Working on new ideas, different things,
creating content, everything.
Behind the screen or in front of it.
I get it!
It's such an interesting,
and I remember Maradona in '86
with the punch.
The fist, yeah.
I watched that game, and so there's things
I've always remembered
and '94 World Cup was in the U.S.
But my soccer
I'm setting up for the vlog that
my soccer skills
(laughs)
are (bleep), zero.
Double zero.
But I'm competitive as (bleep)
and I'm trying,
I'm basically trying to mentally will
a miracle right now.
- So basically the goal is to get the ball
between the legs
if you do that
- Of who, of the other person?
- We would try to do it to you,
and you would try to do it to us.
- Play like one against one
- Understood.
Alright let's go, let's
make a circle real quick.
Okay.
- Perfect.
(hip hop music)
- Wait a minute, wouldn't
it be better for me to
have the bigger bag?
- Three goals to win the game
or a nutmeg that is direct
okay?
- Oh a nutmeg is a direct win?
- Yes, direct win.
(claps)
- Strategy.
- I have a strategy!
I'm not getting nutmegged
on the first (bleep) minute.
(laughs)
Alright, one, nothing.
(group exclaims)
Be careful!
I'm already feeling
extremely accomplished.
- Ooh!
Wooo!
(claps)
- Oh, he nutmegged me!
(laughs)
I didn't even realize I lost!
- That was amazing, man.
Thank you.
My other twin.
- Great.
Super pissed about the nutmeg.
I didn't even realize I lost!
(laughs)
- Great game, great game.
- Thank you so much.
- We couldn't get it better.
- Yes.
Okay.
I'll catch you guys later.
S'up?
Very excited to be here.
You have to understand
what we're living through.
We're living through a race.
We're about to run a marathon
in technology.
Technology will eat up every aspect of
everything, always and forever.
It's how it works.
The bookstores were first,
then it was people who
owned taxi services,
then there's the hotel
industry with Airbnb.
But it will keep going.
The biggest TV networks in the world
now that there's OTT,
this will keep going, everything.
Just 'cause you have
big contracts with the
biggest companies in the world,
what's the contract worth,
when that company's not alive?
This is real.
And so we're about to run a marathon.
And the reason I stress on you to be
good at that
is not because I think that's the
end all be all.
But you have no chance
to be good at AR and VR
and machine learning and cryptocurrency
and everything else that's coming next,
if you did not ground yourself in this.
You can't run a 40 mile marathon right now
on the spot,
if you haven't been on the treadmill
for the last six months
and running little mini races to prepare.
And if you are not adapting this
psychologically, first,
religion, first,
and then becoming a practitioner,
you need to be the architect,
the general contractor,
and the plumber.
Because if you don't, you will lose.
And so
- Thank you.
- Just based of your stuff, right?
Started live streaming myself
making a hip hop demo every single day,
because that's what I'm into.
So, I'm on Twitch now.
- Yes!
- Build that up over the last month,
I was like (bleep),
no one's doing that much in the creative
in the music section right now.
Why don't I lead that up?
So I've been doing that,
I've seen baby steps even for
a small artist like me, right?
One month from starting,
I see Soundcloud plays
every single day now,
go from 10 to 20, 100, 150,
climbing up, so
just want to say thanks
give you a hug.
- Yeah brother.
- Really appreciate everything you do.
- Thank you, man.
Is that right?
- Yes it's true!
- Get outta town!
Get outta town, you knew this?
(laughs)
Ah dude, this is amazing!
It's such a pleasure
- Thank you so much
- Welcome to Sweden!
- Such a pleasure
- It's a pleasure
having you here.
- So fantastic!
- We couldn't miss it
when you were in town.
- I'm so glad you guys came.
- Yes, thank you so much
for everything you done
so much appreciated
- Thank you, thank you.
He's a very special kid.
- Yeah
he really is.
- He really is.
He really is.
That's amazing!
- I'm sorry you have this
weather and everything
- Nah it's fine
- You've been here before.
- I've been here before, yeah
I've been here before.
- So then you know
- I am so glad you guys are here.
(laughs)
This is such a
pleasure for me.
Dunk, look who I found!
(laughs)
The family is finally together!
(hip hop music)
I can do this.
I got that!
(laughs)
That was symbolic!
That was super symbolic
I felt good about that.
There was literally
something about that scene
that was so perfect for me.
Me through you stuck, yes.
She was very senior in this market.
- Thank you Gary for the invitation.
- Yeah of course, great to see you.
The fact that I would have
time to look at something
and think about the bad?
I mean, I don't have time
I don't have time to celebrate
my good friends doing good.
The (bleep) am I doing
spending time trying to
drag somebody?
It's such a bad life,
that I now when I read
his daddy helped him, he sucks,
cocky, ass,
I feel bad!
I'm like, that's
you're using that as the energy
of the output of your life?
You have absolutely lost!
And the other thing and I apologize,
the truth wins at the end!
I mean, I did a sneaker.
I got killed behind the scenes.
He thinks he's a big shot, nobody's gonna
who the (bleep)'s gonna buy a sneaker?
K-Swiss, who gives a (bleep)?
Gary Vee, what does he think he's famous?
Until my sneakers sold out!
In a day!
Then what?
The truth is gonna win.
Either they're right, or you're right.
But you're too important to
spend a (bleep)ing minute on them.
The five percent of people
that you actually need
to win with, mentally
never believe that stuff.
- [Man] The five percent only?
- The five percent of people that
you need to win with in the world
are not paying attention to a headline in
Business Insider.
I started realizing, it started
you know what started happening?
I started getting more trolls,
but more Warren Buffett
and The Rock, winners.
And I said, wait a minute.
If that's happening
at the end of the day
it's gonna be the results.
At the end of the day
Nothing else.
Nothing else!
So to me,
just 'cause people are booing your team
when you're losing in the second quarter
down by 10,
as long as you win the
game at the end, you win.
- [Man] This is good.
- Good.
- [Man] This is karma.
- I know!
My man, you're gonna fuckin',
listen here's the best part,
I know!
You're good!
(laughs)
It makes me so happy, man.
Look,
my whole life has been that.
I got made fun of for launching a website
instead of a second liquor store,
I got made fun of for
doing a YouTube show,
I got made fun of a lot for investing in
Facebook and Twitter,
2007.
My financial advisors were upset!
This is stupid.
What if it goes to zero?
I'm like, but what if it doesn't?
(laughs)
Everybody's on the defense, my man.
You've done something!
The fuck have they done?
Yeah man.
And more importantly, merit will
and by the way it's not
that you and I are cool,
we may be wrong!
They may be right!
But when they're writing from the stands
they have to wait for the game to end.
I mean look,
if somebody came along and tweaked the MLM
network marketing model,
and made it cleaner and less bullshit,
it's real, by the way it happened.
It's called Seamless and Uber.
Like affiliate, it works.
Incentivized works.
You can make anybody do anything if you
incentivize.
I can get everybody naked here right now.
Hundred percent.
Babin, what's your price?
No (bleep), now be careful,
I'll tell you why.
- [Man] When you put it in cash,
that's a big difference
- I agree, I agree.
Watch
But wait a minute,
I'll Venmo you.
I want you to get butt
naked right here right now.
(laughs)
Let's play this out for a second.
In theory, what do you think?
How much?
Like you agree that I can
get you butt naked, right?
- [Babin] For sure.
- Okay.
- [Babin] So immediately
like 10K popped in my head
but then I was like,
Venmo
I just don't know.
- Right, so let's play!
(laughs)
How much money do you think
it would cost right now
for you to literally go right there
literally right there right now,
and get butt naked?
What do you think?
Like, seriously.
And be careful 'cause I'm in a weird mood.
And I'm looking to get 10 million views
on this episode.
What do you think?
- [Man] Are you a Swede?
- [Babin] Nah
- He's from Pensacola.
- [Man] You don't know anybody.
- [Babin] 20.
- 20
(laughs)
- [Man] And then you
should do like Gary do
- I swear on my kids I
might pay you the number
so I need you to really be careful.
And really, because
this is where you could
lose all the equity if you go back on it.
What do you think it would cost
for you to get 100 percent
naked right here right now?
What do you think?
I'm trying to think for myself.
How much would it cost
you to shave your head?
No no, shave the head.
Shave your head
That's an interesting one, you're fine.
What about for you?
- I'm cheap.
- How much?
- I've done it.
- So how much?
- I don't know, a hundred bucks?
- I'll pay that right now.
(laughs)
Let's shave his head,
a hundred dollars.
Right now, right now.
Let's shave his head.
How do we get, like
Can you go into
is there a razor in your
you in?
- Hey I'm game.
It's Finland, I'll do it for Finland.
- For Finland's hundredth birthday
(laughs)
This is amazing.
- I'll pay you 100 if you shave
- I'm paying you a 100
dollars, that's done.
But now, they have a razor
Babin, get on it.
(laughs)
- [Man] Bring the camera
- Leave this, leave this right here
there's gotta be either
it's either in our hotel room,
go downstairs and find
out if they can give us
shaving cream
because I want it to be good for him.
Doing this, 100 percent
Vlog, we're shaving his head, 100 dollars.
(laughs)
Babin, record yourself
- [Babin] I'll vlog on my phone
- Even better.
(laughs)
- So a few minutes ago, Gary
asked me how much it would cost
me to get naked in the middle of the bar.
I said $25,000.
He then asked everyone how
much to shave their head.
The guy next to me said 100 bucks.
Gary told me to go out and buy a razor.
I have a really weird question.
Is there like a pharmacy or
anything open around here
that I can get clippers to
cut someone's hair with?
- [Female] We have a 24 hour pharmacy.
- Okay.
- [Female] So if you
go between those houses
- I just want to say that
if I was in New York,
this would have been handled
in about six minutes.
But because I'm in Stockholm,
everything closes at, like, seven!
Which is providing a
little bit more difficult
- Hi.
- [Male] How's it going?
- Do you guys have razors?
Like in theory I needed
to cut my hair off?
- [Male] No
- Would there be anywhere around here that
would have that, at this time?
- [Male] No.
- Alright, thank you.
Alright, I guess we're adding another L
in Babin's column.
Now I have to go tell
Gary I couldn't find it.
(laughs)
Not gonna go over well.
Which means I might end up having to
take all my clothes off
in the middle of the bar.
- [Gary] Ready?
Vlog, very upset, Babin has failed.
Lev one, Babin zero.
You're very fortunate or unfortunate.
- I'm fortunate.
I want to do it for Finland, you know.
100, 100, boom.
- Yes.
We should shave 100 in his head.
(rock/soul music)